This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s. and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners,
wherever you are in the world. Thank you so much for joining us for another episode. Today is one that I am super, super excited about. Something that we don't talk about a lot on this show is sex and pleasure. And I think that it is really important to discuss. So I don't know why we haven't spoken about it before. but when I heard about this company a couple of years ago, I immediately downloaded their app.
It's an amazing experience. And additionally, I think really aligns with a lot of the values we promote on this show. We talk a lot about psychology, obviously. And I think like everything in our 20s, sex in our 20s is also based in a lot of psychology. So today we are going to talk about it. And I've brought on a wonderful, fabulous guest to join us, one of the co-founders of Dipsy, Gina Gutierrez. Hi. Wow, I'm so happy to be here.
Yeah, thanks for coming along. Can you kind of talk us through what we're talking about today, but also what Dipsy is? Because I think one of the big things about sex in our 20s is that we kind of don't really have like a guidebook. We kind of just go all in. No one's really telling us what to do and we can feel quite disconnected. So where does kind of Dipsy sit in that kind of space? Yeah.
So Dipsy is an app for audio erotica and the stories are all original and we write them ourselves in studio. They're sex positive. They're feminist. They're really fun. And they show what sex could kind of be like realistically but also really aspirationally.
And it's obviously 15 minutes of fun when you're listening to an episode, but they're also amazing to hear how sex could happen or what you might say or what a date could be like that you might really want to be on, or how you might enter a sex club for the first time, right? Like they actually do teach you a little bit about how you might experience things in your own life. And we love that. We love creating a guidebook in a world where there are not a lot of guidebooks. So Dipsy is a brainchild of kind of the combination of what a sexual wellness experience could feel like
and also like a really great storytelling studio could feel like. And it is both. Yeah. And where did you get the idea from? So if you haven't kind of dipped your toes into audio erotica, I think it's amazing. Obviously, as someone who works in like the audio space, I think stories and like really provide us with like an insane ability
to firstly be educated, but also to connect, not just with others but with ourselves. So yeah, where did you get this idea from? think it's like so smart. Well, thank you. So my co-founder and I started the company when we were 27, and I'd been thinking about these ideas since I was in college, so since I was 18. And I remember one of my really good friends coming back to our dorm, and she had just had sex the night before with this guy that she was really into. And she came back and she was like, I really like him, but I just, the sex isn't that good. Why wouldn't that just be automatic if I really like him,
shouldn't the sex be good? So I started asking her questions about the experience, and when I asked her the question, what are you thinking about when you're having sex? She looked at me with this blank stare, and she was like, wow, I really don't know. And something about that moment really struck me that she was so focused on her physical experience, she wasn't thinking about her mental experience at all. So I think many of us understand our brains holding us back from good sex. It's like, I'm stressed out, so that makes my sex drive lower, or I'm preoccupied by a conversation I had earlier, and so I'm kind of dissociated, or I'm overly focused on what I look like or what I'm doing, or I'm, you know, struggling in all these ways. These are actually
like psychological barriers, but we're really not focused on what ways our brain could really support us and having amazing sex. And so how do we have our own bank of fantasy that we lean on? And how do we have language that we use, that we like to hear and guide someone and giving more to us? or that we like to say because we like to say it. And these are these amazing unlocks that really make sex so much better. And storytelling is such an amazing space for that. But the reason that we started it when we were 27 is because common headspace were coming up. And common headspace were showing that you could make an amazing audio experience
that was super immersive and that wasn't there just to teach you something like podcasts we're doing at the time, but to change how you felt. And I firmly believe that storytelling can change how you feel, and I really wanted to make stories that I could feel like that. And I had this hunch that audio erotica could really be this amazing, immersive experience that was imagination forward. So you could imagine kind of your own house on the blueprint that we were giving you with our stories, what characters looked and sounded like, what you looked and sounded like in that story. Where you were, how it all comes together is really up to you to create. And there's something really, really powerful about that that I think is really, really, really. empowering you really are in control yeah i absolutely love that and totally fully agree i really think it's
fascinating what you said around how we recognize the the intersections between our mental framework and our psychology and the sex we're having but we don't recognize it in the moment right we think about it as a barrier not as an enabler so how can we kind of leverage that understanding of of how our mind's working and how our psychology impacts our physical sensations to have good sex in our 20s. I think that's like the golden question that I get asked so much. There's like countless episodes, podcasts about this, you know, articles, people want to know how to have good sex in their 20s. Yeah.
Well, I think first of all, it's answering what good sex is. What makes sex good? I think is a question we don't often ask ourselves. And I think it's a very personal question. and what I would encourage people to think about is start noticing what feels good to you across all avenues of your life. And what I mean by that is I think we have these stories or ideas of what feels good. Like binge watching my favorite show feels good or seeing this group of friends feels good. But then when you do binge watch that show or you do see that group of friends,
you're turning off the TV or you're driving home and you're thinking like, oh, I'm kind of tired. Or I'm kind of just like feeling a little ick or I'm feeling a little bit out of my body. It's really interesting to notice that these things we might have stories about that make a sense. feel good actually don't make us feel good. On the other hand, there are many things that you might do that really surprise you with how good they feel. Maybe there's a new friend that you're spending time with and every time you leave them, you're like, wow, I feel energized, I feel excited, I feel like I laughed, I feel like I was funny, whatever. And you notice that and it feels good. And so I think it's a really good place to start with just being like, listen to the signals of your body of like, this feels good.
I would like more of this, where this actually doesn't feel good. And you might be surprised by what some of those things are. I think we're very distracted. We have screens all around us. We're moving from place to place. We're busy with our jobs. And if we aren't listening to those signals, how can we listen to what those signals might be like in the bedroom? So that's like baseline where I'd start. Yeah. I think solo sex is also kind of where to start. I mean, the American sex education system certainly doesn't talk about masturbation the way I think it should be talked about, where it's a really, by default, safe place for you to explore what kind of touch you like. what you like to fantasize about, pacing, order, you know, you get to start thinking through
what your ropes are. You know your own ropes. And I don't know, I think especially I hear this at Dipsy with heterosexual women who are in partnerships with men who kind of almost assume that men come pre-coded with knowledge about sex. And I can guarantee you that no one comes pre-coded with that. But men often have the guidebook of porn. And that comes with a whole mixed set of messages, some maybe interesting and some really harmful. And so if he or they or she is coming with their own ideas of what sex is and what good sex is, you too need to come to the table with your ideas of what good sex is. So you feel empowered in that and you can stand firm in that.
And the only way you can really do that, I think, is by exploring just by yourself. And so I think like round one, like step one is what does the self-touch or the solo sex experience feel like? Yeah. I, again, I just keep parroting exactly what you're saying. I really, really agree with that. It's really interesting because when I like first started having sex like in my teen years and then even in my like very early 20s, I used to just like define sex as like penetration. And I was literally talking to someone about this yesterday where I was like, I used to be like, all right, it's good sex if like it's penetrative and he can't. And nothing else matters because it's all about like pleasuring them. And it's so interesting because I think when I started to be like really move into this like self-exploration phase, I bought a vibrator. It's the best thing I ever, probably the best $70 I ever spent. And then suddenly it was like not only was I having better sex, but I was attracting better partners.
And I think it also came from this like confidence thing as well and this like sense of self of like, wow, I am having better sex with myself than I've ever had with someone else. So I only want someone to elevate that experience. Yeah, I think if you talk to the average, I mean, maybe this is a little agist, but I think if you talk to the average 40 or 50 year old about sex being this playground to discover who you are and how confident you can be in this world and how much you love yourself, they'd be like, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I think if you say that to a younger person, they're more likely to be like, yeah, totally. Like, this is this underused space where if I have some more, if I pay more attention to what I can do in this space, I might like take that with me out in the world. And I think when people listen to Dipsy, they sometimes say that, they'll say, like, I don't even need to listen right before I have sex. Sometimes I just walk out the street and I'm like, I'm walking with like a skip in my step. I'm feeling good.
I'm like bouncing down the sidewalk. I'm smiling at strangers. Like, that feeling feels like feeling alive. And so I think sex is just one way to be like, how can I like really feel alive and here in this world? And that's, I mean, like, that's so worthwhile, you know? Like, that's it right there in my mind. Yeah. And I think that kind of gets to this point right where it's like you don't need to be,
I think you don't need to be having sex to be experiencing pleasure. I think we often put sex on this pedestal. there's this weird conundrum I found where there's like this shame around having sex but it used to be a lot of shame around having too much sex and now I hear a lot of people see a lot of people with my personal life through this podcast who come to me and are like I'm experiencing a lot of self-shame because I'm having too little. Yeah, classic. Yeah, because I feel like everyone is selling sex to me as this like empowering thing and that I
need to have all of these sexual experiences in my 20s to like form the foundation. of having good sex in my 30s or having these stories. Where do you think that comes from? Because that's something I'm really fascinated by. There are so many shoulds in this space. It's incredible. And I think it's really interesting to me how numbers obsessed we are about sex. We really try and quantify it.
Like how many times a week is normal? What's healthy? What's good for my relationship? And what it all boils down to is all of us asking ourselves, like, am I normal? And it's the number one question. that we get asked all the time, like an investigation of whether I'm normal. And the answer is that there are so many different ways to be normal. But everyone is normal in that.
There's just like different roots to discovering, you know, what's going to work for you. And the shame around, you know, having too much, having too little, I see it as connected to the self-care movement too, which I think net net, very positive. It's wonderful that people have paid more attention to taking care of themselves and addressing when they're over-stressed or over-taxed. But when that starts to tip into, are you doing all this stuff? Are you meditating every day? These are these shoulds, actually. You're putting yourself into a new should space. And so I would, you know, really ask someone to reframe. It's like really not about quantity at all, unless that really
matters to you. It's the side if that really matters to you. But it's actually allowing other people to decide what matters to you. I think what really matters is what feels good to you. And so if you're having a little high-quality sex and whatever that means to you, that's amazing. Unless you feel like you want to be having more of it. Ask yourself that. Is that something that you care about? And start to like create your own ideas of what matters to you, not because anyone has, you know, other ideas that should weigh in on that. So there are going to be expectations in this space all over the place.
I think in relationships, their expectations, when you're single, their expectations. and it's hard to we are social human beings we look to others to help us understand how we move through this world and that's very natural but the shame around having you know two little sex I think now
is a little bit of like this new thing or like the former stigma was like you know you're out there and you're what are all that old fashioned sayings like you're too loose or too easy or whatever words were the words then and I think now the new fear that I hear from a lot of 20-year-olds, you know, 18 to 24 especially, is like, have I had enough?
Like, am I experienced enough? Is it shameful and embarrassing that I'm going out in the world without enough experience? And, oh my gosh, like, you don't need to put that upon yourself. I think that that is actually really getting to such a good point there of, like, the shoulds that accompany sex. And I remember talking to a friend the other day, and I was like, you know, you can have a lot of sex and not much of it can be good. Yeah. You know? Or you can be having sex with one person for your whole life.
And it's amazing. Like, I think that that numbers, that numbers descriptor, that numbers game you were talking about, I see that everywhere in like, oh, what's your body count as well? Totally. I'm surprised by how many people ask that question. I know. The body count thing is interesting. First of all, what a horrible phrase.
It's so bad. I know. I'm like, oh. And the fact that I think that it's like, was first used very much by man. And now it's one of those phrases where we just say it, but we don't actually think about what that actually means. Yeah, let's talk about what it actually means.
Like just right now, because I'm thinking about it for the first time in a long time, which is like sex is bodies and that we are these transactional physical beings and we just transact with one another and we handshake or have penetrative sex in this context and then we move on instead of having some sort of emotional, chemical, interesting interaction with someone, even if that's just purely a one-time moment. That doesn't mean that you're not having a human interaction with someone. Body count makes it sound so, yeah, your personhood is kind of erased from that completely.
Yeah, and I also think that when we think about body count in other aspects, maybe this is a bit of a stretch, but how it's used in like the military and to like accompany the idea of like dead bodies and like this and when they used it in that sense it was like oh what's your body count as this like medal of honor of like how many people have you like dominated killed it just i think is still very much this like descriptor of like to be celebrated the higher your body count the better and especially when we think about its origins in terms of a very historically excessively patriarchal misogynistic society this is normally what it was referring to anyhow we're off track, but I do think that it's like that language around sex really needs to go.
Yeah, and we're judgmental in both directions. I think we're judgmental of single people who have quote unquote too many partners and we're judgmental of long-term monogamous people who have had only one partner and like we're judgmental about whether that's, you know, better or worse, whether you learn more or less, whether you have more sexual experience or less. And I think all of it is just, you know, we're projecting our own insecurities about what's happening with everyone else. But all experiences are. normal and all experiences are valid if they're what you want. And again, it all comes back to what you want. But of course we struggle with that in sex, because I don't think a lot of people are asking us to
evaluate that very often. We don't really flex that muscle. Absolutely not. I also think it links back to very much where we learn sex from. You know, we talked about porn, but also in terms of our education system, the conversations that our friends are having. movies and I recently really was thinking about this in terms of also like your first sexual experience and how much that really determines how you see sex unless you unlearn it. And I think that that also, you know, I don't think most people's first sexual experience is particularly good. You know, it might not be terrible, but like you're kind of just fumbling through it.
and I think that if you think if your entire perception of sex is based off of one experience or like your first experience and how that went and you're not and that's never been challenged particularly what I was talking about before where it's like it's very penetration based and it's very much based on like I'm a heterosexual woman based on what the man wants that takes a long time to unlearned how do you think we can kind of start to unlearn that yeah it's interesting the the idea of, you know, well, I had oral sex and that's not sex, or these are like common things that you hear, you know, in the categorization or the quantifying of like what sex is and it all comes down to ignoring the feelings of it, just focus on the facts of it.
Your question is how do we move away from the idea that the first experience is like this, we overindex on it? I think just like how do we unlearn some of the early things we're talking about sex, the harmful things we're taught about sex, whether that's from our first sexual experience or from porn or from, I think, I think the education system is a bit different in Australia. We don't do amazing, but we, I think, do a little bit better. But even then, the American system is no system. Oh, wow. Okay, so going against zero there. But how do we unlearn some of those things? Yeah, you referenced really early on in the conversation that there aren't a lot of good guidebooks,
and that's something that we, at Dipsy, are very aware of. And I think it, right now, it puts the burden on people to do a lot of self-discovery to find out what they like, but also to like do some unlearning and to do some understanding of how consent can fold into their lives and kind of do the work of being a healthy, sex-positive sexual partner. And that's hard because I wish it was easier for people. It shouldn't have to be so difficult to kind of self-serve on the Internet to figure that out, especially because you might hit a lot of things that you don't want to see or aren't the right information. The internet is a wild west sort of resources. So I think finding sources that you trust really matters. And so at Dipsy, we hope to be one of those sources. You know, you trust the makers.
and that's something that we, at Dipsy, are very aware of. And I think it, right now, it puts the burden on people to do a lot of self-discovery to find out what they like, but also to like do some unlearning and to do some understanding of how consent can fold into their lives and kind of do the work of being a healthy, sex-positive sexual partner. And that's hard because I wish it was easier for people. It shouldn't have to be so difficult to kind of self-serve on the Internet to figure that out, especially because you might hit a lot of things that you don't want to see or aren't the right information. The internet is a wild west sort of resources. So I think finding sources that you trust really matters. And so at Dipsy, we hope to be one of those sources. You're trusting the makers.
They're asking you to pay for this content. It is ethical content by default. If you're engaging with more classic visual pornography, pay for that content. That is the best and only way that you can really guarantee, that it is on the side of ethical porn versus you don't know it's genesis or how it's being made. that you are allowing yourself to expand your understanding what those resources are. Maybe you're really excited about fanfic on the internet
and you're like, this isn't teaching, this is just like the fluffy stuff about sex, it's not. Like you're actually doing active work and understanding what you like, what thematics feel exciting to you and what feels less exciting to you. And those are all resources that are available to you and many of them are actually fun and engaging
and don't feel like you're reading your 18th blog post about consent and still confused. You know, I won't. people to listen to a dipsy story and say like, oh, like, that actually wasn't so complicated. That didn't, like, kill the vibe that actually made it sound even sexier. You know, there's a spectrum from, like, consent to dirty talk, and there's, like, a huge in-between of, like, what it means to verbalize during sex. These are things that are so hard if you don't have examples of what that sounds like.
and don't feel like you're reading your 18th blog post about consent and still confused. You know, I want people to listen to a dipsy story and say like, oh, like, that actually wasn't so complicated. That didn't, like, kill the vibe that actually made it sound even sexier. You know, there's a spectrum from, like, consent to dirty talk, and there's, like, a huge in-between of, like, what it means to verbalize during sex. These are things that are so hard if you don't have examples of what that sounds like.
So people need more resources to figure that out before they're, like, out in the world. Some people are intrepid, and they're like, great, I'll figure that during sex, and they'll learn as I go. amazing. And there's other people that don't feel as comfortable doing that. Of course not. And so, you know, our hope is that there are more resources like Dipsy around and there, there are. But yeah, it's okay to take either path. I think like getting out there and learning is great. And doing the work to learn is also great. Again, like, what's your, what's your path? Everyone's going to have a different path. I love that you mentioned fanfic on the internet. I feel like that was such a introduction for me was like erotic like erotic literature and i remember being like oh my god
I feel so bad I had like um this one book at college and like I actually found it the other day and like the sex in it is so mild like it's so very mild and I was like wow like oh my gosh like this is insane and like I like had the page like dogged and like all that stuff and I'm like I do think that that is actually such a valid thing. Like, I don't know, everyone loves a little bit of a smutty novel. Yeah, it's amazing how many people now that it's getting a little bit more comfortable to talk about these things. You know, Dipsy's been around for five years, and I think five years ago people talked with
this less than they do now. Even, like, the new up-and-coming interest in, like, romance media, like Bridgeton, wouldn't have happened five years ago, which is cool to watch kind of that's happening. And I think part of it is, like, the pushback against misogyny, happening in our culture where it's like, cool. Like, you want to watch football? Amazing. Well, I want to watch a romance piece of media. And I want to watch Bridgeton.
And that's an equally valuable way of using my time. And it's not like chick lit. It's not like worse media. It's like great media that is fun and I love to consume. So I think a little bit of it is like a pushback on there aren't certain types of media that are like by nature worse or better. You actually just get to choose what you like, which I think is really empowering and awesome.
But yeah, we all have the dog-eared book. And we hit the dog-eared book, right? and that was in an era where you had to kind of hide it. Exactly. It's so interesting, though, because I distinctly remember my grandma having, like, do you guys have Mills and Boone? What is that? Okay, so Mills and Boone is like this, maybe it's just an Australian thing,
but it's like this series of, like, smart books, like sexy romance books for, like, the generation of my grandma Yeah. Or maybe even my mom. So like, and they all look exactly the same. And on the front will be like this 80s photoshopped image. And it'll be like the cowboy. Like a horse.
Yeah. Exactly. It would be like the cowboy and the runaway. Or like something like that. It will be like the mistress of Oman or like something. And it's just like, and it's just smart. And my grandma used to have them everywhere when we were kids. So it's interesting that I see.
still felt like shame around sex I think because I was like oh my god grandma that's so embarrassing um but it was so it's so funny because I think that it's just and it I think also she did feel a bit of like shame but then as she got older she was like oh I'm I'm I still feel sexual urges like I still feel pleasure wow that's really powerful to hear that from your grandmother that's really cool she was oh she's she's still alive I don't know why I was like I'm gonna say she was she is like a very empowered lady and I think it, you know, as she got older, that actually became more evident to me. Well, you know, when we were first starting to think about making dipsy not just an idea, but a company, we were looking at the romance novel industry and it's amazing. Like, it drives
the publishing industry. Like, it is the reason the publishing industry is afloat. Literally, Amazon had to create a different package in order to not lose money because romance novel consumers read so many of them that they were like literally taking Amazon out of business. The business model wasn't working. They needed to create a separate package for it. So there's like incredible, voracious demand for this content, but we weren't seeing that demand kind of trickle down to younger audiences. Why is that? Well, like, is the guy with the long hair on the horse, like really the model of what's sexy anymore? Is that it? There's all sorts of kind of baggage that was associated with a category that did really well for our moms and our aunts and our grandmothers. And that's
出版行业。可以说是出版行业能够维持下去的原因。真的，亚马逊不得不推出一种不同的打包服务才不至于亏本，因为言情小说消费者的阅读量太大了，他们简直可以说是要把亚马逊搞垮了。这种商业模式行不通。他们需要为此推出单独的打包服务。所以，人们对这种内容有着惊人、极度渴求的需求，但我们并没有看到这种需求逐渐辐射到年轻受众群体中。这是为什么呢？嗯，就好像，骑在马上的那个长发帅哥，真的还是性感模范吗？是这样吗？关于这一类作品，有着各种各样的固有印象，这些作品对我们的妈妈、阿姨和奶奶辈来说非常受欢迎。而且这
amazing. This is not new. This is just new ways of making this feel cool and content. And contemporary and like it is talking about sex the way that you might talk about it with your friends or like actually have it, you know, out in the world. So I think it's amazing that that existed, but I also think we should be aware that that was very much like relegated as this like silly little woman's thing, which happens a lot where either sex is very, very dangerous or sex is like this like silly, safe little interest. And those are like those are kind of the two places that it can be. You know, our understanding of what pleasure is is really, really, really limited. in the context of Western society.
太棒了。这并不是什么新鲜事，这只是让它感觉很酷、很有内容的新方式。而且很现代，就像你在和朋友谈论性一样，或者说，你知道的，就是在现实生活中真实地经历它。所以我觉得这种存在太棒了，但我也觉得我们应该意识到，它在很大程度上被贬低为“女人的无聊小玩意儿”，这种情况经常发生——要么性是非常非常危险的，要么性就像是一种无聊、安全的幼稚兴趣。这就是性似乎仅有的两种定位。你知道的，在西方社会的语境下，我们对什么是快乐的理解真的、真的、真的很局限。
You know, we've been taught to be good members of society and that our value is measured by what we make or what we do or by our success or maybe by how esteemed we are. And so we see pleasure as like a distraction to what matters most or worse, like a place of no return. Like if we focus on pleasure, we'll ignore all these more important parts of our lives. And so pleasure is generally seen as the stone where it's like allowed to exist if it feels guilty. Like you can have it, but you better feel guilty about it.
你知道的，我们被教育要成为优秀的社会成员，我们的价值是由我们创造的、我们做的、我们的成功、或者也许是由我们受尊敬的程度来衡量的。所以我们将快乐视为对最重要事情的干扰，或者更糟糕的是，视为一条不归路。就像如果我们关注快乐，我们就会忽视生活中所有这些更重要的部分。因此，快乐通常被视为一种带有罪恶感才被允许存在的绊脚石。就像你可以拥有它，但你最好为此感到内疚。
That's like the regulating factor. And I think the way that we treated romance novels for many, many decades was that. It's like, okay, you can have your silly little book. That's safe. But like, let's make you feel a little guilty about it to keep it in check. Because pleasure is seen as selfish. And pleasure is seen as, you know, you need to earn it. And the worst, worst case scenario, it's seen as dangerous.
这就像是一个调节因素。我认为几十年来我们对待言情小说的态度就是这样的。这就好像，好吧，你可以看你那些无聊的小书。这很安全。但是，让我们让你为此感到一点内疚，好把它控制在合理范围内。因为快乐被视为自私的。而且快乐被视为，你知道的，你需要靠努力赢得它。最糟糕、最糟糕的情况是，它被视为危险的。
We're like, once you get a taste, what will happen? And frankly, I think in the context of our patriarchical society, as you just called it out, if a woman knows what true pleasure is, why wouldn't she just leave her husband? Why wouldn't she break the family you did? Why would she be out discovering and exploring? Let's not even give her a taste, right? And those are the containers of thought that we still see. When we talk to our customers, we hear that all the time.
我们就好像在想，一旦你尝到了甜头，会发生什么呢？坦白说，我认为在我们的父权社会语境下，正如你刚才所说，如果一个女人知道了什么是真正的快乐，她为什么不直接离开她的丈夫？她为什么不打破你所谓的家庭？她为什么还要出去探索和发现？干脆连甜头都不要让她尝到，对吧？这些依然是我们能看到的思想框架。当我们和客户交谈时，我们总是听到这样的话。
These are the things I'm afraid of. It's like, if I'm experiencing pleasure, I'm wasting time. Or, like, if I'm experiencing pleasure, that means someone else experiences less of it. Or if I work hard enough and get thin enough, then I deserve something. Like, we all know what that feels like. That second point that you just said then was like, like, I'd never been able to identify that. Which one? If I feel pleasure someone else or feel less.
这些都是我害怕的事情。就好比，如果我在体验快乐，我就是在浪费时间。或者说，如果我在体验快乐，那就意味着别人体验到的快乐就变少了。或者如果我足够努力工作、身材足够苗条，那么我就配得上某些东西。就像，我们都知道那种感觉是什么样的。你刚才说的第二点就像是，我以前从来没有能够明确指出这一点。哪一点？如果我感到快乐，别人就会感到快乐减少，或者感受变少。
Zero sum. Oh, my goodness. Yeah. I'm shocked because I think that that is an attitude that I've had for a very long time. Yeah, definitely. Wow. That was like kind of my poem to me. People are probably listening to this being like, yeah, duh, that's not true.
零和博览。哦，天哪。是的。我很震惊，因为我认为这是我长期以来一直持有的一种态度。是的，绝对是。哇。那简直就像是我的写照。人们听了可能会觉得，废话，本来就不是真的。
But like, I think it was just the way that you were able to describe that. I guess that really, also, I want to say, you're so right when you were talking about the, you know, the cowboy with the long hair and how this generation is not particularly attracted to that depiction. And I really think, you know, that it comes down to people are more interested in a character psychologically nowadays. Say more. They don't want them to be, yeah, they don't want them to be, like, perfect. they want them to be, they want them to have some kind of nuance and some kind of discoverability and some kind of vulnerability that is interesting. It's not just about physical form.
但我觉得，正是你描述这一点的方式。我想说的是，当你谈到骑着长发马的牛仔，以及这一代人对这种形象并不怎么感冒时，你真的太对了。我真的认为，你知道的，归根结底是现在的人们对角色的心理层面更感兴趣。请多说一点。他们不希望角色是，是的，他们不希望角色是完美的。他们希望角色具有某种细微差别、某种可探索性以及某种有趣的脆弱感。这不仅仅关于外在体态。
It's not about being this like archetype and depiction of attractiveness. It's, we are like, we want to be more psychologically satisfied by our character. That's so well said. And you see that in fan fiction. Like you see the kind of like, enemy that is misunderstood and has so much more to offer or the kind of mysterious character that hasn't been fully understood until one person can really see and understand them. I think that's some of the most common tropes that you're seeing happen over and over again. I definitely
这无关成为某种魅力Archetype（原型）和刻板印象。我们是，我们希望我们的角色能带来更多心理上的满足。说得太好了。你在同人小说中也能看到这一点。就像你能看到那种被误解、但其实内涵丰富的“宿敌”角色，或者那种神秘的角色，直到某个人真正看懂并理解他们之前，他都未被完全理解。我认为这是你看到的一再出现的那些最常见的套路之一。我绝对
the biggest example is Christian Gray. Yeah, that's probably from 50 shades of Grey. Like this like torture. Do you think he's redeemable? I don't know. I'm asking the tough questions out here. This is a tough one. Yeah, I actually did read that. I actually read that series over my summer break this year. Oh, really? What do you think? I wasn't a fan.
最大的例子就是格雷总裁。是的，那可能来自《五十度灰》。就像这种折磨。你觉得他能被救赎吗？我不知道。我在这里抛出了棘手的问题。这是一个棘手的问题。是的，我确实读过那本书。我其实是在今年暑假读完那个系列的。哦，真的吗？你觉得怎么样？我不是它的粉丝。
I wasn't a fan. I actually didn't love it. I didn't love it. It was just at my beach house, and I had forgotten to bring a book because I was hiking beforehand, and it was the only thing there. Funnily enough, they actually had three copies. So it was like me. Yeah, so it was like me and my cousin and why,
我不是它的粉丝。其实我并不是很喜欢。我并不是很喜欢它。它刚好放在我的海滩度假屋里，我因为之前去徒步旅行而忘记带书了，那是那里唯一的一本书。说来也巧，他们竟然有三本复本。所以就像是我。对，所以就像是我、我的表妹以及为什么，
of my best friends. We were all reading it at the same time. You book clubbed it. That's fun. We book clubbed it like an accidental book club. What was the debrief like? I think it was like, you know, it was so funny at one point. She won't mind me saying this, but my cousin was like got to this part that I knew was like particularly spicy. And then she's like, I'm just going to go upstairs. I got to tap out. I need private space. Got to go. Yeah. And I was like, you, I think that is so valid. I think like, Al, consensus on it was like this is not actually that appealing because it would be like I think the one thing that I noticed about it was in all the sex scenes it was like she came
我最好的朋友。我们都在同时读这本书。你们搞了个读书俱乐部。真有意思。我们搞了个像是个偶然组成的读书俱乐部一样的读书会。大家的复盘交流是怎么样的？我觉得就像是，你知道的，有一个时刻特别搞笑。她不会介意我说这个，但我的表妹当时读到了一个我知道特别劲爆的部分。然后她说，我得去楼上呆会儿了。我得退出一下。我需要私人空间。我得走了。对。然后我说，你，我觉得这太可以理解了。我觉得，大家对它的共识是，这其实并没有那么吸引人，因为感觉就像是，我注意到的一点是，在所有的性爱场景中，感觉她总是
really quickly she came within like three minutes and I was like and then she'd be like oh a wave of pleasure and then like he just kept going and then we were done yeah and I was like I do think yeah anyhow here's my book review guys no one asked for it but 50 shades a great book review I mean, 50th shades blew open the idea of what a romance novel could be, which I think many people felt was like kind of this dowdy old school thing. And that's cool. Like, that did amazing work. But was it the best written version of what sex at its most aspirational and sexy could be?
很快就达到了高潮，她在大约三分钟内就高潮了，然后我就想，接着她就会说，哦，一阵快感袭来，然后就像他继续做着，然后就结束了。对，我就想，我确实觉得，无论如何，这是我的书友评价，伙计们，虽然没有人问我，但这就是《五十度灰》的书评。我的意思是，《五十度灰》彻底打破了人们对言情小说可能性的看法，在许多人看来，这曾经是一种老土、过时的东西。这很酷。就像，那本书做了不起的工作。但它是关于性、关于最理想化和性感状态的最好写作版本吗？
I think most people think no. You know, the power dynamics at play there could have been a lot more nuanced and the pleasure could have been a lot more mutual. And, like, listen, teach their own. Like, some people love that book. Absolutely awesome. Power to you. But there needs to be more versions of what, like, a really sexy piece of media can look like.
我想大多数人会觉得不是。你知道的，其中发挥作用的权力动态本来可以有更多细微的差别，而快感也可以更加相互呼应。而且，听着，人各有爱。有些人就是喜欢那本书。绝对棒极了。力量赋予你。但需要有更多不同版本的、真正性感的媒体形式。
And I honestly, I give credit to shows like Bridgeton that are trying to figure those things out on the big screen. Which, again, like, wasn't happening five years ago. So I think, like, talk about generational shifts. Like, what millennials are consuming is different than what Gen Z is consuming. Like, it literally is a different world of content out there. 2%. That is the number of people. who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
说实话，我很佩服像《布里杰顿》这样试图在荧幕上探讨这些议题的剧集。这在五年前是根本不可能发生的。所以，谈到代际转变，千禧一代消费的内容和Z世代消费的内容是完全不同的。这绝对是一个截然不同的内容世界。2%。这就是当电梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾深信种子油生来就会引起炎症。我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush did. like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill?
经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。就在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts，或者你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小姬姆（Lil' Kim）胸部的那一幕吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什...不在乎黑人。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小姬姆到底有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析当时的情况，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Marc Lamont Hill）的访谈，畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，84对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode. episode where we've discussed correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. So. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
我随时准备聊聊当年的快克，不过为了让大家了解情况。我的意思是，马克，这已经是我们讨论快克的第二期节目了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条主线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。所以...谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你听播客的地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《硬着头皮学》（Learn the Hardway），我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多杰出的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Trrip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们总是在盯着记分牌看。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），你觉得作为一个活在世上的好人重要吗？
Or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way.
还是说你当好人只是出于恐惧？因为兄弟，这是两种不同的动机。绝对是的。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《硬着头皮学》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。
Open your free, our heart radio app. Search, learn the hard way, and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd, found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用程序，搜索《Learn the Hardway》，立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Echard）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露了她供词中明显的自相矛盾。这拉开了长达数年的法律战的序幕，旨在证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through,
你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试报告，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过相同情况的男性，
the same thing. Greg, the Westby and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
格雷格·韦斯特比（Greg Westby）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or or wherever you get your podcasts. Obviously, we've spent a large part of this episode talking about sex, and sex is fun and sex is fascinating and interesting. People love talking about sex. But there are some other things about your life right now, your experience that I think would be equally valuable to share with people in their 20s.
在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。显然，我们这集的大部分时间都在谈论性，性很有趣，性令人着迷且引人入胜。人们喜欢谈论性。但关于你目前的生活，你的经历，还有其他一些事情，我认为与20几岁的人分享同样很有价值。
The first one being that we have almost a, well, we have a decade between us. so you're kind of like you're kind of me in in my 30s right like you're where I'm at in my 20s in your 30s and I think that there is
首先是我们的年龄几乎相差，或者说我们之间差了有十年。所以你有点像，你有点像30多岁时的我，对吧？也就是说，你处于我20多岁时的状态，而你现在30多岁，我觉得，
at least around me in the people I see this like impending doom associated with turning 30 and it's almost like the clock ticks over one of my friends the other day said to me she was like oh what did she say she was like
至少在我身边，在我看到的人群中，有一种与30岁生日相关的末日即将来临的感觉，就好像时钟刚刚走过那一刻。我的一个朋友前几天对我说，她当时说，哦，她是怎么说的，她说，
30 years when when women die like no longer stab me in the heart i know but i was like i was like excuse me i know i know i was like claire that is not what we want to hear um but you are post 30s how has it been what's it what's been some of the learnings and the new outlook on life if there has been one yeah i think you know i'm 33 so the pandemic started when i was 29 so like right at the tail end of my 20s. I think all of us in some ways felt like we were disrupted. Like, we lost something. We lost college years or we lost like transition years in our 20s or we lost, you know, I lost turning 30. Like that was just lost to the wind of the pandemic. So I think there is something unique and present right here and now. But, you know, speaking from my experience,
30岁的时候，当女人死的时候，就像不要再往我心插刀了，我知道，但我当时就说，我当时说，不好意思，我知道，我知道，我当时说，克莱尔，这可不是我们想听的。嗯，但你已经过30岁了，感觉怎么样？如果有什么收获和对生活的新看法的话，它们是什么？是的，我想你知道的，我33岁，所以大流行开始时我29岁，差不多就在我20多岁的尾巴上。我想我们所有人都在某种程度上觉得自己受到了干扰。就像，我们失去了某些东西。我们失去了大学时光，或者在我们20多岁时失去了过渡期，或者我们失去了，你知道的，我失去了庆祝30岁生日的机会。这一切就像是被大流行的风吹走了。所以我觉得此时此地有一种独特而真实的感受。但是，你知道，从我的经验来看，
my 20s were interesting because 10 years ago, 15 years ago, it wasn't as common as it is today to have queer friends that were out of the closet when I was 18 or when I was 20 or even when I was 23. I had plenty of friends that one of my friends affectionately calls baby queers that were figuring out what it means to feel safe out in the world as someone who has stated as queer. And for those folks, you know, you're working through that feeling of you should be more experienced but aren't and that can be really challenging your 20s. And I think there's versions of that that happen in our 30s too. Like we are all baby queering in some ways where maybe you hit 30 and I've had this for plenty of friends and you're deeper in monogamy with someone. You've been
我的20多岁很有趣，因为10年前、15年前，不像今天这样，在我18岁、20岁甚至23岁时，有那么多出柜的酷儿朋友。我有挺多朋友，其中一个朋友亲切地称他们为“酷儿宝宝”，他们当时正在摸索，作为一个被认作酷儿的人，在外面世界中感到安全意味着什么。对于那些朋友来说，你知道的，你在克服那种“你应该更有经验却并非如此”的感觉，这在20多岁时真的很有挑战性。我想30多岁时也会有类似的版本。我们在某种程度上都是“酷儿宝宝”，也许当你到了30岁——我许多朋友都有过这种经历——你与某人的亲密关系进入了更深的阶段。你已经和某人在一起很长时间了，然后你会想，嘿，我其实想弄清楚，不是怎么去过性生活，而是怎么去过美妙的性生活。那对我来说会是什么样子的？因此，我实际上看到很多人的兴趣在28、29岁左右开始飙升，当时人们会想，我正在踏上一段自爱之旅。我想爱自己的身体。我想享受性。我想扩展我对性的理解。也许我想敞开我的关系。这里面有更多的探索，不仅仅是我想要性，而且我想尽可能多地拥有它，而是我真的想专注于质量。我认为这确实是30多岁的一个巨大转变。
with someone for a longer time and you're like, hey, I actually want to figure out not how to, not how to have good sex, but how to have great sex. What is that going to look like for me? And so I actually see a lot of interest start to spike in maybe like the 28, 29 zone where people are like, I'm on a self-love journey. I want to love my body. I want to enjoy sex. I want to expand what my understanding of sex is. Maybe I want to open up my relationship. There's like, like more play happening with not just I want to have sex and I want to have as much of it as possible, but like I really want to focus on quality. And I think that that's really a big shift in the 30s.
就像，我如何真正专注于对我来说什么是质量，这太棒了。我觉得人们总是在谈论随着年龄增长压力会变小。我是说，我不知道，你在不同的方面会感受到压力。但我认为，这种“我需要去，我不知道，数一数我跟多少人有过性关系——用这个词来形容太糟糕了——但就是那种走出去，推着自己往前走”的感觉会稍微少一点。我很累，但我周四还是要出去。我觉得我们在30多岁时，普遍来说没那么强烈的这种感觉了，但我们仍然可以真正关注我们性生活旅程中所处的时刻，而且它并没有结束。你知道，生活当然不会在30岁时终结。
It's like, how do I really focus on what quality is like to me, which is amazing. I think people always talk about you feel less pressure as you were older. I mean, I don't know, you feel pressure in different ways. But I think there's a little bit less of this like I need to be out, I don't know, tallying my body count would be the worst way to say it, but like out there and like pushing myself. And I'm tired, but I'm going to go out on a Thursday. We feel that less, I think, generally speaking in our 30s, but we can still really attend to the moment we are in our sexual journey and it's not finished. You know, life certainly doesn't end at 30.
我喜欢33岁。我喜欢进入30多岁。我想我绝对可以说，我现在比10年前更爱自己了，我希望这种爱能继续增长。而且，你知道，旅程一直在那里，性欲也是会变化的，对吧？比如你可能23岁时性欲非常低，因为你的老板太糟糕了，你工作时间极长，或者你有身体羞耻感、身体形象问题，有各种各样的事情在发生。然后你可能会从那种状态中走出来，在33岁时迎来复兴。你可能在40岁时迎来复兴。我们在生活中拥有最棒性爱时刻，绝对不是被限定或束缚在20多岁的。
I love being 33. I love being into my 30s. I think I can definitely say that I love myself more now than I did 10 years ago, and I hope that that keeps growing. And, you know, the journey is always there, and libido shifts, right? Like you might be 23 and have really low libido at the time because your boss is horrible and you're working super long. long hours or you're having body shame images, body image issues, and there's all sorts of stuff going on. And then you might come out of that and have a renaissance at 33. You might have a renaissance at 40. The moments that we're having the best sex in our lives are certainly not
事实上，我想大多数与我交谈过的、度过20多岁的人都说，他们现在享受的性生活比那时更好。所以它就在你前方。值得期待，但还有更多的人生要去经历。我认为对性自我探索的更大兴趣是我感受到的最大转变，你知道的。那对我来说是什么样的？那感觉会是怎样的？我要如何把它激发出来？
maintained or like bound by our 20s. I think actually most people that I speak to that are past our 20s say they're having better sex now than they did then. So it's ahead of you. Look forward to but there's a lot more life to live. I think the greater interest in sexual self-discovery is kind of the big one that I feel by, you know. What does that look like for me? What's that going to feel like? How am I going to bring that out?
我要去上什么课？我要去上一个绳艺（Shabari）课吗？我要通过舞蹈课学会爱自己的身体吗？我看到了更多这样的现象。它稍微更有意图一些，我真的很尊重这一点。什么是绳艺课？绑绳子。所以这是一种复杂的艺术，但也是一种涉及绳索和结的非常规的BDSM形式。
What class am I going to take a Shabari class? I'm going to learn to love my body through a dance class? Like I see a lot more of that. It's a little bit more like high intention, which I really respect. What's a shabari class? Rope tying. So like a complex kind of art, but also like a very, form of VDSM that involves knots and ropes.
哦天哪，哇。太迷人了。就是这样。我又学到了新东西。我以前完全不知道那是什么，但超级超级酷。听到这些我也觉得很好，最美好的还在后头。这真是一种潮流，听到这些，我确实认为我们20多岁是追求数量的年代。
Oh, my God, wow. Fascinating. There we go. I'm learning more. I had no idea what that was, but super, super cool. It's also good to hear, I think, that the best is yet to come. It is such a trend, like, hearing that I do think that our 20s are like the quantity years.
是的。我们就像是，我能有多少次性经验？我能喝多少酒？我能参观多少个国家？我能赚多少钱？就像所有事情都是——是的，就像我只是想要每样东西的最大值，最大的快乐。说实话，这挺累人的。是的，有时候我只想——我就觉得，我只要最低限度就好了，我也挺满足的。好吧，也许这就是我能为30多岁代言的另一件事，我认为
Yeah. We're like, how many sexual experiences can I have? How much alcohol can I drink? How many countries can I visit? How many, like, you're mosing really hard. money can I make like everything is like yeah it's like I just want the maximum of everything the maximum pleasure um and it's kind of tiring to be honest yeah sometimes I just want like I'm like I'm cool with like the bare minimum well maybe that's another thing that I can speak to the year 30s for I think
你给自己留出了更多的余地去感受你正在感受的情绪，如果那种情绪是疲惫，那也没关系，而且这真的很解放。我是说，你，我不确定你是否熟悉“小睡部”（The Nap Ministry）这个账号，但我认为围绕着解放有非常强大的内容，它来自于允许自己去感受你的感受，如果那种感觉是疲惫，那就去拥抱它。是的，我认为这也是心理学上的一个巨大转变，以前主要是治疗消极想法、治疗自我批评、治疗正在发生的任何事情。而治疗它的方式就像是通过羞耻感把它们从我们体内驱除，或者压抑它们，或者就像是，去跑步吧，去把这个做了。
you're you give yourself a lot more leeway to like feel the feeling that you're feeling and if that feeling is tired that's okay and uh that's really liberating I mean you're you're like you're I don't know if you're familiar with the account, the NAP ministry, but I think it's like really powerful stuff around liberation coming from allowing yourself to feel what you feel and if that feeling is tired to embrace it. Yeah, I think it's also a massive shift in psychology as well of previously it was around treating the negative thoughts, treating the self-criticism, treating whatever's going on. And the way to like treat it was to like shame it out of ourselves or to suppress it, or to be like, go for a run, like, go and do this.
去转移注意力。而现在，它更像是，实际上，你需要去和那种情绪共处。任何其他做法实际上只会加剧那种感觉、那种痛苦、或者那种冲动。所以你真的需要去拥抱好与坏，我认为这是积极心理学和更整体心理学的一部分，正在新一代心理学家中真正兴起。所以超级迷人。我想谈的另一件事是你的创业之旅。我知道这其实确实和性有关。我知道这就像是一集专门讲性的节目。显然你创立了Dipsy。那段经历怎么样？因为我想我们在录音前就在谈论这个。我们当时就在想，这就是那个。
Go and distract yourself. And nowadays, it's more like, actually, you need to sit with that. Anything else is actually just going to exacerbate that feeling, that distress, whatever that urge is. So you need to really, like, embrace the good and the bad, which I think is, it's like a part of positive psychology and, like, more holistic psychology that's, like, really coming through in this, in this, like, new generation of psychologists. So super fascinating. The other thing I want to talk about is your journey through entrepreneurship. I know it has actually does have stuff to do with sex. I know this is just like a sex episode. Obviously you started dipsy. How has that been? Because I think we were talking about this before we started recording. We were like this is how that. Yeah. Yeah, I know. We should have
是的。我知道。我们本该那时候就开始录音的，但现在这样依然会很棒。是的，关于你的创业之旅，我觉得每个人都对你是如何创办一家公司、是什么构成了公司以及所有这些事情着迷。你能给我们讲讲吗，你之前在其他地方工作过吗？了解整个旅程以及你的路径会很棒。是的，我的意思这可能需要几个小时，所以我尽量简短。所以在创办Dipsy之前，我是一名品牌战略师。所以我一直在帮助品牌弄清楚如何通过他们能够真诚提供的产品去迎合受众，并讲述人们喜欢、感兴趣的故事。
started recording then, but it's still going to be great. Yeah, around like your journey through entrepreneurship, I feel like everyone is fascinated by how you can start a business, what makes a business, all of those kinds of things. Can you talk us through, were you working elsewhere before? Like, the whole journey would be great to hear your path through. Yeah, I mean, this could take hours, so I'll try and keep it brief. So before I started Dipsy, I was a brand strategist. So I was helping brands figure out how to meet people where they are with what they could authentically offer and tell stories. that people liked were interested in.
所以讲故事一直是其中一部分。我本科读的是心理学。哦，很好，我之前不知道。我一直对人们想要什么、是什么驱动了他们，以及为什么他们做的事和他们声称自己想要的并不一样，感到非常好奇。真的就是，你知道的，非常吸引人的东西，也就是人类行为的基底。
And so storytelling was always part of the mix. I studied psychology and undergrad. Oh, well, good, I didn't know. And I have always been really curious about what people want, what makes them tick, and why they do different things than what they state that they want. Just really, you know, just fascinating stuff, just the baseline of, you know, human behavior.
然后我遇到了我的联合创始人，那正是在我有了这个想法的时候。我想，当你把这个想法付诸实践——比如我要辞职了，我不会有收入了，我要把所有的鸡蛋放在这个篮子里——的时候，如果有一个对这个想法同样充满热情的人，绝对会大有帮助。所以我觉得当其中一人感到有点焦虑时，我们真的互相支持，
And then I met my co-founder, and it was right around the time that I had this idea. And I think the moment that you take the idea to the reality of, like, I'm quitting my job, I will not be making money. I'm going to put all of my eggs in this basket. Definitely helps when you have someone who is equally passionate about that idea. So I think that we really supported each other when the other was feeling a little bit like,
另一个人就会在那儿，你知道的，每个人每次只允许一个人崩溃，对吧？所以在这些方面我们得以互相平衡，并觉得，不，这真的很吸引人。研究就在这里。虽然我是一个天生的讲故事的人，并且很高兴去弄清楚这些内容听起来会是什么样，但Fay是一名工程师，Fay知道如何打造产品。所以我们几乎是实现这一目标的完美团队。因此，寻找一个与你很契合的人，同时也是一个你真正信任和喜欢的人，是非常重要的。就像你要花
ah, the other person was there to be, you know, there's only room for one person at a time to be having a freak out, right? And so we got to balance each other in those ways and be like, no, this is really compelling. The research is here. And while I was a natural storyteller and was excited to figure out what this content was going to sound like, like Fay is an engineer and Fay knows how to build a product. And so we were kind of a perfect team to make it happen. So I think finding for someone that you have good fit with, but also someone who you really trust and really like matters a lot. Like you're going to be spending
这么多时间——无论你选择谁作为你的商业伙伴，如果你走这条路的话——所以选择至关重要。我想说的是，在过去五年里，这甚至比我的浪漫伴侣还要重要。如果你敢相信的话，我们花了太多时间在一起。在很多方面，她就是我的另一个伴侣。真的吗？哦，听到这个其实觉得挺美好的。还有那种从辞职到开始做这件事的转变带来的恐惧，真的是太吓人了。
so much time with whoever you decide to be your business partner should you follow that path. So that selection matters. And I would say that mattered in the last five years even more than my romantic partner. If you can believe it, we've spent so much time together. Like in many ways, she is my other partner. Really? Oh, that's actually quite beautiful to hear that. Also, that fear of, like, transitioning from being, like, I've quit my job to doing this. That is so scary.
真的很吓人。
It's so high conviction, right? Like, you are really saying, like, I really believe this. And then you are asked questions every day to push back on whether what you believe is true. And so you have many chances a day to be like, do I still believe this? Right. And you really just have to keep believing it. And I think that if that feels exciting, because you feel such high conviction in something, that's amazing.
信念感太强了，对吧？就像你真的在说，我真的很相信这一点。然后你每天都会被问到各种问题，来质疑你所相信的是不是真的。所以你每天有很多机会去想：我还是相信这个吗？对吧。而你真的必须继续相信下去。我觉得如果这让人感到兴奋，因为你对某事有着如此坚定的信念，那真是太棒了。
And otherwise, wait for an idea that really makes you feel that way because that conviction will be tested on a daily basis, and there will be many people that don't believe. And that's hard. That knocks your ego. I really had to work on my self-esteem through that problem. Like, what if not everyone thinks this is what I should be spending my time doing? What if not everyone thinks this will work?
除此之外，那就去等待一个真正让你有这种感觉的想法，因为这种信念每天都会受到考验，而且会有很多人不相信。这很难，这会打击你的自尊心。我真的不得不通过那个问题来建立自尊。比如，如果不是每个人都认为这就是我应该花时间做的事呢？如果不是每个人都认为这行得通呢？
What if not everyone thinks this is important? It's hard enough already, just every day, figuring out how to do it. But it's harder when other people don't necessarily think it's, yeah. Does a 50-year-old white man who my dad's business partner think that dipsies as important as a 25-year-old who is so excited that this product exists? Of course not, but there are people like that. And so finding the people that remind you of why this matters to you and reminds you of this being important along the journey is also really huge. We were talking about that earlier too. It's helpful in the world of podcasting are alone a lot.
如果不是每个人都觉得这很重要呢？光是每天弄清楚怎么做就已经够难了。但当其他人不一定觉得它重要时，那就更难了。我爸的商业伙伴那个50岁的白人男性，会觉得迪普西（Dipsies）和一个对这个产品存在感到无比兴奋的25岁年轻人一样重要吗？当然不会，但确实有这样的人。所以在旅途中，找到那些提醒你为什么这件事对你很重要、提醒你这件事意义重大的人，也是非常重要的。我们刚才也在讨论这个。在播客世界里，经常一个人独处，这很有帮助。
It's helpful to get out there and be like, wow, I meet you. really like what I'm doing. That's amazing. It's also interesting what you were talking about, the idea that comes along. I watched this amazing TED talk the other day. That was explaining how ancient civilizations used to think that the ideas lived in the walls and in the wind. And so, like, an idea would come to you in the wind and you had to, like, grab it. And you had, like, a responsibility to grab it out and hold onto it super tight. because and you can see the ideas like floating by I think a lot of people have like
走出去，然后发现，哇，我遇到了你，你真的很喜欢我在做的事，这很有帮助。这太棒了。你刚才谈到的那个关于想法诞生的观点也很有趣。我前几天看了一个精彩的TED演讲。它解释了古代文明如何认为想法存在于墙壁和风中。所以，一个想法会随着风来到你身边，你必须去抓住它。你有一种责任把它抓出来并紧紧抓住，因为你能看到这些想法飘过，我3认为很多人都有这样的经历
million dollar ideas on a daily basis I think everyone has had a million dollar idea but it's like they just let it float by and they know grab it and it is it takes a lot of courage to do both things I think it takes a lot of courage to be like oh you know I actually have a family right now and I can't do that or I need to focus on my studies but also a lot of courage to be like you know I think that was my experience I was like the first couple of month's first year it was like I didn't get any listens I really it was just like my family and close friends and it just was like you just got to push through and believe in what you're doing exactly maybe those are my two biggest learnings is that possible could I boil out to two that'd be a miracle but
每天都有价值百万的点子，我觉得每个人都曾有过价值百万的点子，但问题是他们就让它这么飘走了，并没有抓住它。这两件事都需要很大的勇气。我觉得一方面，你需要很大的勇气去想：哦，你知道吗，我其实现在有个家庭，我做不到这一点，或者我需要专注于我的学业。但另一方面，也需要很大的勇气去想：你知道吗，我觉得那就是我的经历。前几个月甚至第一年，我几乎没有听众，真的，基本上只有我的家人和好朋友，当时的情况就是，你必须咬牙坚持，坚信你正在做的事情。完全正确。也许这是我最大的两个收获，这可能吗？如果能提炼出两个收获简直是个奇迹，但是
I think you know what you just said is so right like there are some people that say like I have the grit and I'm willing to push through it and I'm willing to deal with a year maybe even more where I'm not getting the feedback that I want yet but I just believe and I keep pushing and there are other people think like that actually sounds more terrifying than fun. And I don't know if I have that sort of grit. And I actually feel really happy pursuing something where someone is telling me what they need and I'm doing my job really well. And that is an equally respectable path. And in many ways, I envy that in my hardest days because being entrepreneurs like, oh my God, the responsibilities on me all the time or me my co-founder all the time. So talk about the shame thing. It's like, there's no shame
我觉得你刚才说得太对了，有些人会说：我有这种毅力，我愿意咬牙坚持，我愿意花一年甚至更多的时间去面对我还得不到想要反馈的阶段，但我就是相信，然后继续坚持。而另一些人则会想：这听起来与其说有趣，不如说更让人害怕。我不知道自己有没有那种毅力。而且，如果去追求某种别人明确告诉你有需求、而我又能把工作做得很棒的事情，我会觉得非常开心。那是一条同样值得尊敬的道路。而且在很多方面，在最艰难的日子里，我甚至会嫉妒那种状态，因为当创业者意味着：天哪，责任总是落在我一个人身上，或者落在我跟合伙人的身上。所以谈到羞耻感这回事，其实就是，完全不觉得羞耻
in finding what works for you. And entrepreneurship definitely isn't for everyone. But if you really feel excited to hold tight to that idea and like you just want to prove and like great grab it and your 20s are a great time for that because you're full of energy and like you know what else are you doing let's just try it and so it's an amazing time it's an amazing time also I think if you fuck up it's like that was my whole thing I was like I have nothing to lose by doing this I have nothing to lose like if I fuck up yeah it's like I really was like and also when are when am I going to do this otherwise like yeah when else am I going to take this risk you know in my you know things could happen at any point like yeah you have children you have
去寻找真正适合你的东西。创业绝对不适合所有人。但如果你真的对紧紧抓住那个想法感到兴奋，想要去证明它，并且能够牢牢抓住它——你20多岁的时候正是做这件事的好时机，因为你充满了活力，而且你想想，你还能做什么呢？那就去尝试吧。所以这是一个绝佳的时期，也是一个好时机。而且我觉得如果你搞砸了，那就那样呗。我当时的全部想法就是：我做这个没有什么可失去的。我没有什么可失去的，如果我搞砸了，那就……我当时真的是这么想的。而且，我什么时候还能再做这件事呢？不然我什么时候才能冒这个险呢？你知道的，生活随时都可能发生变化，比如你有孩子了，你有
a mortgage like you're getting promoted your family member's ill like I need to go back and do this like do my masters I need to like I think that it was just such a sometimes everything just kind of aligns yeah but like you will be tested I've learned that like the universe the universe like something like I think that anything worth having isn't easy
房贷了，你升职了，或者家里人生病了，需要我回去重新做这个——去读我的硕士学位，或者我需要……我觉得有时候一切就是刚刚好契合。但是，你一定会受到考验。我了解到，宇宙，宇宙就像是……我觉得任何值得拥有 Dinge 都不容易
otherwise everyone would have it so wise and I know that such like it sometimes people like yeah sometimes people give me like give me a little bit of flack for that they're like a lot of things that are worth having it easy but I'm like yeah but I think that there are some things that aren't you know
不然每个人都能得到了。这太有智慧了，我知道有时候人们会因此而……有时候人们会对我有点微词，他们会说，有很多值得拥有的东西其实并不难。但我想说的是，是的，但我认为确实有些东西是并不容易的，你知道的
like not everyone everyone wants a gold everyone would want an Olympic medal right the phrase that I like to use is like what game do you want to be playing and what pain are you willing to tolerate? And so maybe you are the kind of person who can really deal with challenging personalities. And that's just like kind of, you know, water off your back. It's not super stressful to you, but for other people, that's like intensely uncomfortable. And so maybe, you know, being a nurse in a hospital isn't the job for you because that is like sort of pain that you'd be encountering on a daily basis. Okay, so maybe that's not the game that you play.
就像不是每个人都想要金牌，每个人都想要奥运奖牌一样，对吧？我喜欢用的一个短语是：你想玩什么游戏？你愿意承受什么痛苦？所以，也许你是那种能够真正应对充满挑战的个性的人。这就像是水过鸭背，对你来说并不是超级压力大。但对其他人来说，那会让他们感到极度不适。所以也许，在医院当护士对你来说就不是一份好工作，因为那是你每天都要面对的那种痛苦。好吧，那也许这就不是你要玩的游戏。
but yeah life is I think about picking the games that you want to play and knowing that like no path is going to be like default wonderful there's all there's so many things about being entrepreneurs are so wonderful you pick who you work with you choose the problems you want to work on you decide how you want to spend your time and you own that time like those are really amazing things but the downside of that if you don't like it is you feel like oh my god I have all this time what am I supposed to do with it how am I supposed to organize it how am I supposed to use it I have to pick people that's so hard like I don't like hiring I find that really stress like there's all so sorts of ways that you can see the same thing in two different directions. And yeah, so probably I could bring that all the way back to what feels good for you. Like, if you're paying attention to what feels good for you and you're like, I end this day feeling like it was exhausting, but I'm not depleted. I'm just tired. Cool. You know, there's a difference there.
但是，生活嘛，我觉得关键在于选择你想玩的游戏，并且明白：没有任何一条路天生就是完美的。当创业者有很多非常棒的地方：你可以选择和谁一起工作，你可以选择你想解决的问题，你可以决定如何度过你的时间，并且你拥有这些时间——这些真的是非常棒的事情。但如果你不喜欢它的缺点，那就会觉得：天哪，我有这么多的时间，我到底该拿它怎么办？我该怎么组织它？我该怎么利用它？我得去挑人，这太难了，我不喜欢招聘，我觉得那压力好大……所以，看待同一件事，可以从两个完全不同的方向去看。是的，所以最后其实还是可以回归到——什么对你来说感觉最好。如果你在关注什么对你感觉最好，并且你觉得：我结束这一天时虽然感到筋疲力尽，但我并没有被掏空，我只是累了。很酷，这里面是有区别的。
Gina, thank you so much for coming on the show. This is possibly one of my favorite episodes. I don't know why I hadn't spoken about sex. some pleasure before. There is so much psychology and, like, so many facets of it that definitely need to be explored more. I want to also say this episode was not sponsored. I just really love dipsy. It was not sponsored in any capacity. However, if you do want to download this app, experience some amazing storytelling, some amazing audio content that's a little bit different to mine. You can go to what's it, dipsy.com slash psych 20. No, you can head to dipsystories.com
吉娜，非常感谢你来到节目中。这可能是我最喜欢的单集之一。我不知道为什么我以前没有谈论过性或某种快感。这里面有太多的心理学知识，以及很多肯定需要做更多探讨的方面。我还想说，这一集没有赞助。我只是真的很喜欢 Dipsy。它没有任何形式的赞助。不过，如果你确实想下载这款应用，体验一些精彩的故事、一些与我的内容略有不同的小众音频内容，你可以访问，什么来着，dipsy.com 斜杠 psych 20。不，你可以前往 dipsystories.com
slash psych 20. That's d-I-P-S-E-A stories.com slash psych 20. There you go. And you get 30% off. You'll get 30 days free. So you can export literally every piece of content to your heart's desire for 30 days and decide if it's right for you. Oh my goodness. Look at that. It's free. You may as well do it. You may as well just download it for 30 days and listen to some fun stories. Do some exploring. Yeah. Do some exploring. I think that's really, really valuable. And I would also definitely say follow us on TikTok and Instagram.
斜杠 psych 20。也就是 d-I-P-S-E-A stories.com 斜杠 psych 20。就是这样。你可以享受七折优惠。你还将获得 30 天免费体验。因此，你可以在 30 天内尽情享用几乎每一项内容，并决定它是否适合你。噢天哪。你看，它是免费的。你大可以试一试。你大可以下载它 30 天，听一些有趣的故事。去探索一番。是的，去探索一番。我认为这真的非常非常有价值。我也绝对想说，请在 TikTok 和 Instagram 上关注我们。
We put all sorts of fun content, educational content out there. That's at tipsy stories on both TikTok and Instagram. I think the stuff we put up there is amazing. And our social media manager is a wizard. Actually, I did see something on TikTok the other day. And it was like one of your stories. Like the audio of one of your stories. And like, yeah.
我们在那里发布各种好玩的内容、有教育意义的内容。在 TikTok 和 Instagram 上都可以搜索 dipsy stories。我认为我们在那儿发布的内容非常棒。我们的社交媒体管理员简直是个奇才。事实上，前几天我在 TikTok 上看到了一个东西。就像是你们的一个故事。就像是你们其中一个故事的音频。而且，是的。
And it was like over this like tree backdrop. up and I was like, wow. Who we targeted you effectively? Oh, my God, my algorithm was like, and I follow it in the algorithm? I follow you guys, but not, yeah, yeah. But like this one in particular was like, I was like, pulling me out. Yeah, it was really good there. I literally was like, oh, I need to go listen to a cute little story.
而且它背景是一棵树。当时我就想，哇。我们精准定位了你吗？哦天哪，我的算法就像是……而且我还关注了这个算法？我关注了你们，但是，对，对。但特别是这一个，就像是，把我吸引过去了。对，那里的内容真的很棒。我当时简直就是，哦，我得去听听这个可爱的小故事。
Thank you so much again for coming on. I really think that what you're doing is amazing. Thank you so much for listening to today's episode. As always, if you feel cool to do so, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple podcast, Spotify, wherever you're listening right now, make sure you go and check out Dipsy, of course. And if you have an episode suggestion, if you just want to follow along, please follow me at That Psychology Podcast on Instagram and on TikTok to see what's coming out, to see what we have in the works. We would love to see you over there. And as always,
再次非常感谢你来做客。我真的觉得你正在做的事情非常了不起。非常感谢大家收听今天的节目。和往常一样，如果你觉得可以的话，请随时在 Apple Podcasts、Spotify 或你现在收听节目的任何地方留下五星好评，当然，别忘了去看看 Dipsy。如果你有单集的建议，或者只是想关注我们的动态，请在 Instagram 和 TikTok 上关注我 @That Psychology Podcast，看看有什么新内容，看看我们正在筹备什么。我们很希望在那里看到你。和往常一样，
have a lovely week. We will be back with another episode in a couple days. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and hosts care games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
祝大家度过美好的一周。几天后我们将带着另一期节目回归。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Care Games 主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间主要探讨黑人男性的经历，进行一些在任何地方都无法真正安全地进行的坦诚对话，而你是与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士在交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它。请在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023 年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这段怀孕经历似乎是一个骗局。你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试报告，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。互联网侦探们出动了一大批人，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人，
Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
格雷格·吉莱斯，迈克尔·兰奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨戴尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。请在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on. on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%? That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一面蜕变成一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》？也就是在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听数字 2% 播客。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that Trust your girlfriends Listen to the girlfriends
当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《The Girlfriends》。
Trust me babe On the Iheart radio app Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcasts This is an IHeart podcast Guaranteed Human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《Trust me babe》。在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个 iHeart 播客。经真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。